hey guys i'm ryan wright and i'm jerry
and this contact is bothering me and
it's my one contact i have left this one
does not have a contact so if i do weird
things in my eyes throughout the video i
am sorry but i need to be able to see
the trailer or at least some of this at
least some of the trailer because this
trailer is a movie that's been postponed
like three times yeah this is seventh
sun starring jeff bridges and julianne
moore a fantasy adventure movie and a
lot of people have been saying should
check this trailer out
so jerry
let's do this all right just so you know
i don't know anything about it but i
already think this is going to be a
horrible movie
because jeff bridges in fantasy yeah
like jeff bridge i love jeff bridges but
lately he's been popping up and been
like dude you were so good like 20
minutes ago
let's see let's see what old jeff has
for it
legendary
i'm gonna leave this place soon
and you this day would come
be wise
be careful everything you ever need is
inside my son
i've been searching for you mr ward
you are the seventh son of a seventh son
an order of noble knights combating the
forces of darkness
it says here that there are a thousand
of you they won't die
we are all that's left
teach them
live in the world now where legend and
nightmare are real
oh whoa
what the hell is that wrong
the devil is upon us
oh
your sweet has returned
the world shall fall
if you see a witch
kill it
we're not all evil you know
i can't do this
oh
join us
okay interesting
all right maybe you want me over a
little bit no no it's like it starts out
and you're like oh it's another one of
these yeah
you're from an ancient order seven son
of the seven son we got our cool
terminology for why you're gonna help us
protect some kind of ancient evil jeff
bridges pops up a lot now to be like i
am the last ancient guy who's going to
help you become a hero like i'm going to
guide you on your journey
yeah like so
like wicked sick oh gosh
it's been a rough week ah apparently um
no no no they say in presentation you
shouldn't
bring negativity into the picture or
else no it's realism oh yeah you're
right stay in the life of rice this
trailer reaction show is art
well yes and then it kind of rides on it
being real yeah
unreal with two e's that's how we'll say
real for that one
like a white like wally but no as the
trailer progressed it was like okay
there's some pretty cool creatures and
then you're like these are some awesome
creatures actually because
it looks like what i was worried
hercules would be like this self-serious
okay like kind of boring but there's a
lot of monsters and still kind of boring
film yeah like this one looks like it
has really interesting creatures that
are like a hybrid of like total fantasy
and then they have like some that are
just realistic like a giant bear yeah
and um i wonder if that's jeff bridges
and jefferson
oh and jeff bridges uh looks pretty
[ __ ] crazy he's already becoming
believable as it progressed at first i
was like yeah i don't know no you don't
know still the whole time i love jeffrey
see the thing is i'm afraid that the
whole jeff bridges can do no wrong thing
has gone a little too far because like
lately i'm so used to him popping up
being like ah i'm your stoic guide to
becoming a hero and i'm kind of weird
like i'm drunk and tired but it i kind
of bought it as this one progressed
looked like he was having fun like
that's what this movie looks like to be
it looks like a fun adventure yeah no it
looks like a fun adventure he just looks
like mr cockburn but in medieval times
and yeah doing that thing where he
doesn't really enunciate anymore but i'm
gonna explain you some [ __ ]
i don't know if this is based on a book
or not like i don't know what its source
of origin is exactly but it looks like
it has a throwback vibe you know in some
ways yeah yeah classic type of kind of
like disney horror no way well yeah and
then the creatures and stuff like that
whole part of the trail looks really
cool and that's when i started getting a
little more engrossed in it yeah yeah
you know like oh this isn't what i was
expecting at all you have jaimon hansu
as like main secondary bad guy yeah or
at least is what it looks like it's
actually digimon homizoon yeah did you
mind the gmon digital monsters digimon
are the champions
not really though you look back when
you're like that was a shitty song
yeah
champions what you hear the pokemon song
today and you're like that's a pretty
cool song still a pokemon song is like
an 80s rock
song it's like yeah yeah because you
gotta catch them it's you and me like
it's so it's so cheesily important i
know it's my destiny pokemon oh you're
my best friend
in the world we must defend
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you know we have nostalgia here we have
we have like oh we're
it's like
they talk like real people we're like a
judd apatow movie oh hopefully oh and uh
jerry has a playlist too reasons to
jerry check out his [ __ ] has movie
reviews while he's driving which are
awesome
and then he does other [ __ ] sometimes on
occasion but check it out hey jerry bear
yeah
is it is it that time again it's that
time again it's that time again shout
outs colby willis you guys have the best
reaction videos on youtube can i get a
shout out
of course colby willis well you know
where this is going are you related or
bruce willis
are you like i know this guy named greg
i talked about this a couple episodes
ago and uh greg hates it whenever
someone hears his last name oh yeah he's
not into that and he's like and then
everyone's like are you related jessica
i used to call him uh greg albums he
used to call him he didn't he was not
girl with that at the time he used to
call him eggs i did instagram well
because he's into eggs he really was an
egg a lot of eggs from my understanding
he still likes eggs today oh i believe
it
anyway colby willis this is not about
greg it's about you kobe not kobe willis
colby you're the [ __ ] you stay that way
continue taking shits they're good for
your calling gamer bigfoot this guy he's
a gamer
and he's fat
interesting he's got feet a foot he's
got one foot he doesn't have feet
actually what oh oh he's just got one
big foot yeah so he's got like a unileg
or do both of his legs meet at the foot
they're a uni-leg oh wow i know it's
amazing well done that's gotta be
difficult that's gotta be kind of
awesome if you can make that work you
must have an incredible sense of balance
what if he was like an amazing kickboxer
i you know hey well there's a well
there's a way all jump kicks yeah yeah
you should have had a picture of
yourself but that's what i'm gonna
imagine every time i hear your name now
i just imagined a big sasquatch you know
huddled over some kind of game control
sasquatch like the fruit yeah no the
vegetable kumquat i think you're
thinking kumquat yeah
that's not when you sasquatch or a
squash
kumquat squash kumquat like when a bunch
of guys cheers on a girl no it's called
[ __ ] bukkakee
porn education that's what we offer here
in the real rejects michael perez hey
hey rejects could i have a shout out and
ryan you should watch saving private
ryan expendable style
that does sound pretty funny oh no that
act yeah
yeah michael perez that's a great
suggestion actually that sounds [ __ ]
hilarious dude michael is a good name
just like in the bible
matthew mike luke and joe yeah matthew
mike the gospel according to mike all
right guys don't even listen to that
here's what happened right jesus was
hanging with me all right yeah that's
what the gospel is just chilling right
now like peace and love everybody that's
yeah the gospel michaels is really
conversational he's like he was such a
chill dude he brought everybody bread
like
he didn't have to do that but like he
brought snacks refreshments there was a
party we ran out of wine so he made more
because we had all this water and
everyone's like we don't have we don't
have to drive like we all live down the
street because like in this day and age
who needs to drive we need to drive yeah
we all live in the same neighborhood
yeah it's like we donkeys pull us home
the only reason we are the only people
we know is because we live in the same
neighborhood and cannot commute further
than this yeah it's like we have the
marketplace and we have our homes and
like this the church the synagogue but
like whatever in order to commute that
means you're moving
yeah yeah yeah that's that's who michael
perez mike perez easy uh
stoner from jesus's times and he wrote
part of the bible
that is michael brown more you know